okay you've got me online tom haven't
you yeah
okay brilliant thank you i'll mute
myself thank you right
good morning committee good morning
officers good morning other members
who've joined us for the morning so
welcome to
our meeting of external ons first of all
this new municipal year
22nd of july 2020 can't believe that the
last time we met was january the 22nd
which was 182 days ago um
so it's uh incredible that so much time
has passed
in that in that situation and um
the whole world seems to have turned
upside down from one way to another
um just interesting to read this morning
um looking at statistics when we were
dominated by covert
that i see now we've reached just past
45 000 losses of life which
we're sad for anybody who's gone through
a difficult time a loss of loved one etc
etc
there's three hundred thousand nearly
confirmed cases
and the most incredible figure i found
for this morning was that they reckon
that there's 64
189 excess deaths for the
corresponding period of last year which
when you think about it that is nearly
the same population
as torridge so what has happened in this
year since the 22nd of july
is that the sad losses of the time has
been equivalent nearly to the population
of torridge and
it makes it you know we talk about
numbers and
look at numbers and look at statistics
but if you just think that's a number of
excess tests in that time it shows you
what a dramatic time we've all lived
through
nationally worldwide pandemic wise etc
etc
so what we're gonna do this morning is
go through the committee agenda
that you've all got in front of you um
can i uh go first of all to
situation number one agenda item number
one apologies for absence please
any apologies mary
chair we have had no apologies however
can i just read out the attendances to
make sure that all councillors are
present
please do yep cancel a quarter honking
here councillor ford
goes to the forward that's the fortunate
immune is here
yeah councillor
council mckenzie president
councillor newton yes mary
councillor penton uh here
mr topham
mr topham present
thank you okay thank you very much
for the sake of youtube who may be
watching can i just ask um
which officers are with us supporting us
today we have a very good team of
officers supporting the committee
um and can i just ask them to show their
faces um
um and just say they're here and what
their role is within torah's district
please so we know who is
is watching um for our members of the
public
so overall to our wonderful officers can
you just introduce yourselves please as
well
janet williams i'm the environmental
health and community safety manager here
at turrage
thank you uh i'm sean carney i'm the
planning economy manager and an interim
basis a member of the senior management
team
uh toric here to support you chair thank
you very much indeed for your support
i'm stacey dorey i'm the senior sister
and monitoring officer at torridge and
also a member of the
senior management team thank you and
um we've got the valuable mary
can you just say hello mary hi mary
richards democratic services officer
over to tom us okay
and then we come to tom as well tom van
stern democratic services
okay so so thomas our computer wizard as
well so he um
keeps us up straight and narrow so that
it's good and going anybody else i've
missed i do apologize
nobody i've missed okay so if any of you
members of the public are watching
welcome this morning and we are grateful
that you're attending and watching
the purpose of this committee is
external ons
overview and scrutiny uh the role of the
here on the target is to monitor our
partners both
um in the uh public sector sometimes
in the private sector and some of the
strategic partners we work with such as
citizens of vice bureau
and tourist tolerantly voluntourage
tall and tourist voluntary services um
things like the aonb
the area of outstanding natural beauty
the biosphere
so that we maximize benefits for the
residents of torridge and we as a
committee choose our topics
um to maximize and gains
for our residents within the area so
that's the
remit that we work we are critical
friends of all the partners we work with
and one of the questions we always ask
ourselves as committee is how we can fit
in to best serving the public
with other partners as well so that's
what we're endeavoring to do as critical
friends
on external ons now with that i'm now
going to move to agenda item number one
and we've been through the apologies for
absence
and i'm grateful that all the members of
the committee are here this morning so
we've got a
a full ternary and i'm grateful for the
work that mr phil topham
an independent member uh he's not
elected but he always serves the
committee he gives a view outside the
political arena
um to come to this committee i'm
grateful for the work he's put in
so no committee we go to agenda item
number two which is pages
three to nine on your agenda
and i first of all would like um just to
ask for accuracy
and i'm going to go through page by page
anything that you feel
inaccurate of the meeting of the 22nd of
january
so page number three at the bottom
i don't see any hands going on page four
page five page six
page seven page eight
page nine we've got a fire alarm go on
here in turret at the moment that's
nothing
to do for me is it i haven't got to
leave the building
no it's all gone quiet okay um
okay uh so can i have a proposer that
the
minutes are accurate please
i proposed then i was there at the time
any second is for accuracy
oh second second who is that please
christopher harding
yeah thank you very much indeed
can i just have some guidance guys i've
got a bell behind me going on
here at the moment i don't need to leave
the building die
testing chair that's testing was testing
me
right thank you very much for accuracy
um we'll sign those minutes when i get
next get a chance i've not got a copy in
front of me but that is an action that i
will have to take to sign those as a
correct
record uh we had no meeting at all on
the fifth of march
and then coronavirus uh intervene in the
meantime so there's no other minutes to
read from that point of view
chair you've got to take a vote on those
minutes yeah sorry apologies
can we take a vote please uh mary do
your usual
best i forget we're going to take votes
here mary please can you do
the ring around cancel
hankin
cancer afford
council afford
abstain
thank you council harding four
abstain chair because i've apologized to
the chair for missing that meeting i got
a family
uh issue at the time and has completely
missed the january meeting i have
apologized
so i'll abstain from this except his
apology accepted the apologies
can you record that as a late apology
even though we can't technically add it
as an apology to the meeting please
yes chad councillor mckenzie
four councillor newton
abstain i i wasn't present
mary eight
thank you so therefore
minutes have been accepted i will sign
them at an appropriate time
when i have a copy in front of me
any matters arising from the minutes
that what people want to pick up that
are
not on the forward plan that we will
come to the at the next
agenda sorry the action list um
on agenda item number four so any
minutes or matters arising
okay you have two hands raised
councillor ford and phil topham
right let me get my participants up and
right councillor ford please
hello hello councillor ford
um yes uh chair i'd just like to
put on record my gratitude and thanks
for uh federal members
for acknowledging the work i put in
reference the fire service
um didn't go unnoticed i should have
brought it up before but thank everyone
for the appreciation it makes my job
worthwhile thank you well thank you very
much for your comment
and then we have also then
uh phil topham please uh yeah
three items share on page one of the
minutes that's page three of the agenda
pack at the bottom
matters are rising yeah there was a
mention of an update on appledore's
shipyard which would be available at the
end of the month
which would be the end of january was
there
ever an update sean can you give us any
up-to-date information
that you may have on the shipyard please
uh ch
so chair that thank you there was there
was actually never really an update
we've had several different um
unofficial uh
notices if you like from people about
what's going on down there but actually
there is nothing to announce yet
you might have picked up in the press uh
an announcement from the unions
uh earlier this week a lot back into
last week
about a potential buyer for the site um
this is a it's a rumor it is potentially
a strong rumor but
we don't we can't confirm that anything
that was said in that is correct yet
we're awaiting announcements from
from government are you happy their
response mr topham yeah thank you very
much it's just a captcha
really and i know it's a difficult and
busy time but i thought it's quite
probably quite a good idea to pick up on
some of these things in case any of them
are
important the next one yeah before i
pick up the other two points can i just
ask if councillor ford has heard
anything about the shipyard down at
appledore
yes council for just on the shipyard i
wonder if you've heard anything
uh down on the upper side no basically
i've only
heard and i think um hop and bring this
up very important obviously for my area
and for the area as a whole
um all i've earned again is rumors
because apparently
i think there might have been some
release on tv or something referenced
the
union uh remark um
but basically as sean curry's probably
saying
you know it's nice if the gates do open
but until they actually open i think we
can't jump the gun but um i have
obviously uh people have come up to me
quite a lot um
almost assuming it was there yet
thank you okay thank you now back to
mr topham again you have two further
points on the matters arising
yeah the next one's on page three of the
minutes that's page five of the agenda
pack right at the bottom
uh resolved two recommendations relating
to 16
10 yes shall i read them too
chair if you've not got them or i've got
them in front of me um oh yeah
yeah i just wondered what what what is
happening with those that's
all or whether they're still on the
to-do list
i guess i respond yes right we've got
that as minute
69 on the action list which sean may
fill us up when we come to the action
in a moment if that's okay with you mr
topham absolutely fine
thank you and your third point uh yes
it's the
presentation from petrol again page five
of the minutes yeah he left us with two
questions mr mcknee at the end
yes and i wasn't sure whether we had
ever actually
convened to answer his questions for him
and whether it might be useful to do so
at some point
well what i think might come out this
morning when we come to our forward plan
which is going to be the center of our
morning's work i suspect
is that given the difficult times facing
18 to 24 year olds
um i think there will be a whole set of
questions that pet truck will be
centrally involved in
um and meeting what i think is going to
be quite an urgent
social need in the wake of this sad
pandemic for
that particular age group um how are you
can i ask you you we hang on and deal
with that and then bring petroc into
that discussion
for that age group absolutely that's
fine
thank you chad okay okay anyone else
with matters arising
i see no hands in front of me at the
moment
i just got a couple i wanted to ask um
on page two which is page four of the
agenda sean
we did ask about if there was a um
an inquiry about the the board member
representing westwood housing board
because
um torquel went to westwood housing some
years ago
there was board representation from
torridge but there seems to be very
little board representation now
for residents to go through and i i
i asked the question then at the time if
there was any
uh representation through a tenant and
i i was waiting for a feedback on that i
don't know why that went into the
minutes
um but it should have may have been gone
at the action plan
can you update us on that comment on the
third paragraph of page four
or page page two there are page four of
the administers
let's find cherry it's in the action
list as well so we'll cover both things
off of one seat
so so yeah i mean i think this came
about because we used to as a district
have representation on the board
of taka when we first transfer further a
housing stock
um due to uh time elapsed that's no
longer a requirement and we don't have
representation on that board
of westwood anymore um and and done a
bit of research
but i haven't spoken to barbershop
direct but done a bit of research
i can't see that there is tenant
representation on the westwood board
but they do run what's called a senate
where they um they discuss things with
between the board and a representative
panel of tenants
to get feedback so um i think that's how
they get that sort of inclusion there
okay so so um so there is a means of the
voices being heard from the tenants
of um the ex talk and now westward
social housing tenants and effectively
yeah they run a senate scheme so
basically they use it as a sounding
board to
test ideas with and take feedback on
things from
their tenants okay thank you very much
for that update from that point of view
no matter further matters arising
then we go to agenda item number
three which is public participation have
you had any representation
guys tom um from the public democratic
services
no none at all okay thank you very much
for that
we go to agenda item number four which
is your action list
on page 10. and
[Music]
it seems a distant memory some of these
things so um
let's begin on minute number 25
it was raised by mr topham and
it was a request for janet williams to
complete pilots
to be invited um under
the forward plans item to be referred
back to the 4th of march meeting
uh janet do you want to comment on that
uh yes apologies for that chair
um i i didn't actually do that um
but obviously we're looking at the
forward plan um today
so um you know from that i'll be able to
update
the the list of contacts that i've got
and then we'll have that available for
committee in the future
thank you very much indeed any questions
to janet from the committee
don't i got a hand there from councillor
leather
yeah thanks well i i copied off the
extra documentation yesterday that
janet's put around
yeah um that
we've still not had a statement on the
finances as such of the community safety
partnership
and certainly we've not had an
attendance record we've got a list there
of who the attendees could be but when
we had the meeting last year
um some of us would like to know how
many of these people actually ever
attend any meetings
and of course i see there isn't yet a
schedule for meetings for this current
year
of the cps okay
and i did send out the um uh
2018-19
um 1920 finance
um summary uh yesterday i apologize if
you haven't got that
um i thought that had been circulated
you're right about the
the csp list um apologies that was a
misunderstanding on my
part i thought it was just a list of um
attendees for the uh for the for the
meetings and but i can clarify that we
do have very good attendance at the at
the csps
and certainly the one that we had um
three or four weeks ago because it was
done online
and we had excellent attendance um but
we haven't actually set our dates
and for the uh the the meetings going
forward
and there's been a lot of other
community safety meetings going on
so our chair didn't feel that a specific
csp meeting was was needed
and however we are in discussions with
with north devon about reinstating those
and getting a program back on course and
for this year
and so we should be able to um update
everyone on that shortly
okay um another hand
cursor leather your hand's still up do
you want to come back please
yeah just to come back yeah i did print
off the final evaluation report
which has come from the police and crime
commissioner's office
yes and i've looked through that i've
seen the very some projects that money's
been spent on
but really what i was hoping we'd have
would be a budget
so that we could see how much money
there is and this is just a list of some
of the projects that money's been spent
on
i still don't know how much money is
there if it's all been spent in the
budget
or exactly what the total budget is it
for a year
okay uh just to confirm cancel the
leather
um we get 12 and a half thousand pounds
from the opcc
every year and that is um essentially uh
the csp budget for for torridge
and the information i sent around
yesterday was the return
to the opcc um as part of their
monitoring of spend so i think it said
in there that we were slightly overspent
by about 80 pounds um but it also gives
the
the details of what the last year's
funding allocation was was spent on um
if you want further detail i can
i can provide that but essentially
that's what's gone back to the
opcc um and for the funding allocation
for this year we've done a
a similar um exercise where we've um
allocated the funds to various projects
or areas
and that's also just been approved by
the opcc
um so i can i can provide further
information
on anything that you want on that but
but essentially that's that's
um our spend and that's what's been
approved by the uh
police and crime commissioner's office
okay
uh thank you for the response john thank
you for all the information you sent
out yesterday with the attendees list i
have
got a copy in front of me but i haven't
had a chance to look at all the uh
files that are attached to it that you
can actually look at as well so i do
apologize that i've not
read fully all the street marshals
returns
etcetera etcetera to see exactly how
it's fitting in together
do we as a committee have a statutory
responsibility to meet with the
csp once a year is that correct is my
interpretation of the
of the underpinning law or that's right
yeah the csp has to report back to a
democratic body once a year so it's
normally at the end of the year
but we can add that to the forward plan
when whenever committee sees fit
well i can say we met in october last
year
i think it was october the 29th um with
toby davis is that the same meetings
that's the same one yes and that was a
giant one with norse devon on that
occasion
okay um and maybe when we come to our uh
forward plan um this one of the areas
i think we ought to be working jointly
with north devon district council on
um and and maybe we can answer some of
councillor leather's
points um and get some details and
prepare for that meeting
at that time if the committee is agreed
that we take that position on that with
the forward plan
can i just have some indications that we
can
detail that minute to tie that in with
the possible meeting in
october which we are obliged to hold
anybody in agreement
yeah i got three or four hands right can
i make that a proposition
so that we can move forward on the
minute 25 then
that we we move this forward to the
forward plan
we are saturated obliged to have a
meeting with the csp jointly with
devin and we try to arrange that for the
late october november meeting our
proposal is their seconder please
council color honking yeah i'll second
that
i've got a second there from country
color honking any other proposals
none can we go to the vote please mary
councillor harding or
councillor hawkins oh
no for the language for
councillor or councillor mckenzie
four councillor newton
paul councillor pennington
four mr topham oh
cheers that's unanimous thank you very
much mary
thank you again for those information
you sent out janet as well there's um
a lot to read and take in there and i
look forward to more information when we
come to that relevant meeting at the
time
returning to agenda item number four now
the second minute on the
action list number minute 49
um again raised by mr topham um
and that's to refer recommendations
relating to the csp
uh to the environment health and
community service safety manager
um just update us where that's got to
please
whoever is in democratic services
chair janet's response actually follows
that
piece that's involved so janet's not
saying since the meeting i've been
nominated it's on the slides can you see
the slides
okay so um so so we are
are we as a community satisfied with
that with that item
anybody wish to raise any further points
or you feel the item has been dealt with
i have a hand from councillor leather
well
just to refer chair to what you
mentioned the
the report that came from the precinct
crime commissioner's office and those
attached
reports well i clicked on them on the
screen i couldn't get them up
so to look at those reports that are
annotated against
there i wasn't able to look at those i
don't know how we access those
you mentioned them chair and you added
as i mentioned i got them but they're on
the right hand side of them yeah
and when i clicked on those on the
screen they said they don't come up so
they're not attached as such
then we make a note of that if we can
please
okay any further points on minute 49
then we moved to minute 57 and
uh this was raised both by council
langford and myself
um it was to play strategy
um for members of the public we torres
do a play strategy
um sean kearney is the lead officer and
he has been allocated sean he will
explain to you as members of the public
the play strategy and uh the update of
the minute which is
to uh there's a tenant representative oh
we've already dealt with that sorry yes
apologize
our attendant board on on uh westwood
housing that explains
where the issue came out of um
coming thinking that through now is
simply because of access to
play areas and the responsibility to
play areas within torridge
i think coastal langford you raise the
same issue is is that your recollection
recollection as well um i mean
i think the the main thing was um
because i specifically was concerned
about one play area that westwood
housing are now
um responsible for um unfortunately
there was going to be a tour of westwood
housing by councillors that we were
invited
to and i mean that got cancelled because
of the lockdown
so i'm hoping that if that's reinstated
at some point
or some further communication between
councillors and westwood housing
i could get to the bottom of my query
because i've tried to contact westwood
housing directly and and
i'm finding it very difficult to find
out exactly what the position is about
this
area of land it's actually about in
green in in my ward
that i was concerned about and and that
was where this came out of
um was there a tenant representative on
the board but
i mean i completely understand um
sean's um information about them having
a panel where they talk to tenants
that's fine
and i'm the play strategy itself i'm
pretty sure will come up
in in what we're going to talk about
later in the meeting anyway
thank you sean do you want to add any
comments at all
no notes here i think it'll be picked up
later on we'll pick that later on so if
minute 57 is now
completed i don't see any other hands
raising issues there
i have a hand against coastal leather
again
yeah thanks chair well from what council
langford says i do agree that
westwood housing we ought to be able to
i know we've not had
i think the meeting we were going to
have at uncle valley road there
and the lockdown prevented that there's
no reason why we couldn't have a zoom
meeting with westwood housing
in lieu of that and be able to put some
questions directly to them then because
the bowdoin green player of course has
been stripped of all its play equipment
and you know we'd like to know what's
happening it's very important
for many hundreds of our residents
throughout torridge
is how westward housing conduct the
running of what used to be the council's
house in stock
and certainly the play area is a big
issue uh
so you know we've got lots of questions
we'd like to put which we would have had
the opportunity
to do if we'd been able to conclude the
visit to
to their offices on clavelli road so i
you know when we're looking at our
forward plan i think we certainly
ought to get some meeting in with them
on it
thank you then we'll note that and with
with your agreement we take that
forward to the forward plan if that's
okay with the committee
say if you're against or want to add a
further comment to that i
want to save time without going through
every vote and recommendation
um stacy may tell me off solicitor from
that point of view but for
fck his speed um we will come back to
that
under the forward plan i see i have a
hand from council newton
chair thank you just to support what um
councillor lester was saying that
what was arranged was just more of a
familiarization
visit uh for councillors to go and have
a look
if actually um this became an agenda
item where um the
housing provider was actually uh invited
to come
to committee then we would have a better
chance an opportunity to scrutinize
their activity
uh in a more deliberate way
um that the the meeting that was
arranged wasn't that type of meeting my
understanding was it was a
i come and have a look at us but um i
think if we are going to challenge them
or we we want to ask more detailed
questions it should be done in a more
formal setting of a of a committee
hearing and they actually uh
coming and presenting to us and then we
uh able to challenge them on certain
things thank you
okay thank you for that um
just balancing that through i don't want
to lose the thoughts coming through
here and the need to to address but we
also may have a fairly forward forward
plan um we can always adopt a position
um where where we ask uh possibly a sub
group
um to meet with westwood housing where
there is specific issues
of this council um is that a possibility
stacy
am i uh just making sure we work within
the constitution of torridge
um because it is a very important uh
issue for many of our residents
are could we put if we have a busy
forward plan
have a small group meet with with uh
westwood
to make these representations
yeah if if um ons are content to
delegate that to
a smaller group and report fully back to
the committee there's nothing to stop
you from
from doing that if you want to agree
that that today
okay then what we would do is is with
your agreement committee
um defer further until later in this
meeting
where we look at the floor plan if you
wish a committee to make an absolute
uh formal presentation at the committee
at some point we can request westwood to
come
or we can delegate a small group
who have specific interest in this area
um to go forward are you agreed that we
can
go forward and deal with this under the
forward plan
at a later point in this meeting just
say if you're against and i'll call for
a vote if you if anybody's against that
please put you if you want to add i see
no hands going up before me
so what we could do it will come back
now later in this meeting to discuss
in the four plan the action we will take
with regard
to the uh minute 57.
then we move to minute 69 raised by
myself
um i think it was a proposition at the
time from jamie
mckenzie and seconded by me about
a report coming back from 1610
um sean can you um enlighten us or the
property team is
entitled to sean can you speak on behalf
of the property team
yeah of course of course council
pennsylvania the
uh what we can say well first the mata
is now closed it's
it's been the works have been done the
pumps are working and uh boilers are
fine
and uh we've we did talk about it at a
property in
major projects working group so so that
that so that's that matter close
but uh just for your assurance uh we are
after having our experts look at those
facilities down there
100 certain that what uh marcy from 1610
has said at the meeting about us not
installing the right boilers was
actually inaccurate
those boilers work the proper boilers
they have been fit for purpose
and we feel that it was probably um
perhaps maintenance issues that of
course some of the issues so
um i don't think the allegation that we
put the wrong equipment in was fair
that's very strong sean thank you very
much for your comment any questions
committee
to to
[Music]
sean on that matter
i have a hand from
phil topham mr topham our independent
member
thank you chair yes um this
there were two recommendations one was
to do with the boilers which was
which sean has just covered and then
there was another recommendation about
the review for me for significant
capital investment
in measure services generally
recognizing that the
perhaps the infrastructure of all the
leisure centers is a bit run down
and it does mention in the minutes that
perhaps there is
a need for provision for leisure
services in the strategic priorities
now there is also a proposal for an
environment and leisure services
committee to be set up so my question is
would that be the group
that would address possible strategic
priority of capital investment
in leisure services right now that was
the
same minute 69 credits the laws raised
the comment there at the bottom of the
page is not
deemed necessary um raised with leader
and the
constitution working group um i wonder
if states
stacey um you could comment on the the
thought behind that please
i'll have to get back to you cancer
palington i i don't
recall that uh being raised at the
constitution working group and i haven't
had a discussion with the leader so i'm
i'm i'm not sure i can report back later
on
um but i running through the suggestions
that are raised at the constitution
working group i don't recall it being
and put forward right okay so so we've
got um
two things going on there with minutes
on the two minute 69s
um clearly um from our report from our
uh um
our uh from sean kearney then um
on and from the property team that the
borders are in good order
and uh um everything is working
correctly
um i think your committee are not
questioning that from sean's report any
longer
um so that part of 69 is closed
um but can we just get a come back on
coach of topham and just ask the second
part of minute 69
is kept alive just to get a response on
on
why it was not deemed necessary at the
time it was um
uh an issue that was raised
um and i was at the constitutional
working group and i've got the minutes
beside me but that met on the 12th of
february
um i can't remember um exactly what was
said at that meeting without going
through the minutes
now and going through there so can we
leave the second part of
minute 69 to come back to our future
meeting
does anybody disagree with that please
just show
i see no hands going up so can we keep
that
as a forward on our action list please
chair mr topman has raised his hand
sorry phil
yes please i i
i can hear what you're saying about
clarification about the committee
proposal but
the issue of a need for significant
capital investment
i'm not quite sure where that will go
that recommendation
if there isn't such ability and clearly
i think this recommendation has come
because
we've had a number of meetings with
leisure services and it's clear that
infrastructure
is an issue there are systemic problems
that need big investment
maybe not the time for big investment
but that recommendation has been made
um thank you for that from my overview
and scrutiny point of view
we as a committee can never make a
decision we can only make
recommendations and when it comes to
spending it will always go
through full council or cnr for for the
final decision making on the process
but our role as a committee is to work
with our partners
and from from those partnerships make
recommendations to the relevant
authorizing committees as the role is um
and um it's our job to continue to
monitor
and put forward recommendations as so
necessary um any different comments on
that please let me i got another hand up
here can here come in yeah who who's
that please that's sean
speaker i can't for some reason i don't
want to handle the rings yeah inside
so it's i have to rudely interject so
sorry um
there's a there is a process for this
already in that um
the the decision-making powers of the
old environment and leisure services
committee i think were
consumed by the new community and
resources committee in
in in such so you have a committee there
but in terms of the deciding on capital
expenditure you do an annual review
of the capital program and you as
members allocate
the capital funds as you see fit at that
point now if somebody
well you know if there are a large piece
of work around our leisure estate
which we're constantly reviewing and
obviously have a mind on
with with all of this uh covered
response and
an imminent ends to the contract if
there are a recommendation for
large capital expenditure in in our
leisure estate
that would then be reported to you as
members and the various scrutiny
committees it goes to on the process
before getting signed off by full
council
so we come back before this committee
again sure
uh it could do yes i mean i'd say i in
terms of the
normal um approval process for the
capital program i think that goes
through internal
okay um but uh
i'm sure we could find a way of of
discussing things related to it at this
committee
or perhaps it would be a joint committee
as as we've held
over things like grants and other things
okay
back to mr topham yeah apologies if i'm
being a bit slow or ignorant here but
where then has that recommendation for
significant capital investment
now being placed to be considered chair
chair i don't actually recall there was
a recommendation it's not
is it it's we didn't take a vote on a
recommendation
i i don't know that we've debated it
sufficiently to be making
recommendations like that but that's
entirely
up to you
[Music]
oh right okay that's fine sorry i didn't
recall that
okay okay we're looking at uh pastry
then
and it resolved the following
recommendations
be made a review of need of
significant couple of investments in
partnership with outside
agencies to be taken
comments and opinions for an expert
engineer of 1610 and regards to the
borders supposedly be included on the
action list
um subject to a satisfactory conclusion
be discussed further at property
and a major projects working group now
um i should have looked up property
major property working group actually to
check
on where that second point's gone but
there was still a
clear first agenda resolution there
um that we do review the uh the
significant capital investment so chair
so can you come back on that i've
reported on the second point that it was
actually discussed at a property in
major projects working group so
that has that action's been forwarded on
right um in terms of the first one
that's pretty much the day job
to be honest that's what we have um our
team
property team doing um and our and
our community engagement officer will be
working
um with with members to understand their
priorities moving forward in terms of
what we want to achieve in in leisure
but
um i don't know whether stacy would
agree i don't know that that
unless you desperately wanted to needs
to go anywhere because we are constantly
reviewing
the need for capital significant capital
investment
against the priorities that you've
already set now if you change the
priorities in the strategic plan
then we need to review our expenditure
against those
new priorities so that might be a
something to consider after the strap
plan okay
um i okay i see a handgun up here let's
just
coaster newton um
i support that in that surely with the
the need for uh contract renegotiation
coming up fairly soon anyway
um this the whole issue of capital
investment is
is going to be part and parcel of a
contract renewal because because
no company is going to go anywhere near
it unless they they know
uh exactly what the investment plan is
yep any further comment
yeah can i just interject and and just
let members know there is a
an update to all members coming shortly
in relation to this specific issue so i
would suggest that prior to making any
decisions at ons today um you
members wait for the update and that
will inform your thinking going forward
it's a confidential one which is why i'm
not
elaborating at the moment because it
will be a part part two element of a
meeting on monday
councillor leather yeah just to uh
agree with councillor newton on what
he's just said when we
look to renew our leisure contract of
course any pro
any possible contractor or anybody
considering taking on the contract would
want to know what the investment program
is from tory's district council what is
needed to be invested
what we what they expect us to invest in
and what they
bring to the table as well so and as
stasis just said this would be a
confidential report coming out
so it is in process in that actual fact
this is in process
thank you very much indeed council
another so
hearing comments i hear um mr topham's
point of view
i hear um our officers and councillor
newton councillor
leather um can we move forward and take
the leisure facilities forward to
generally dealing with in the future
forward plan the forward plan
so that we can reassign that because
the picture with funding is hugely
changed
um from the point of view of the
pressures that will come on
future funding given the circumstances
since the
these minutes of the 22nd of january so
if we look at
a fresh in the forward plan it will be
probably more accurate
would you agree as a committee we can
just do that from that point of view we
we put it
to look at it in the forward plan in a
new light
and because we've had a previous
recommendations agreed i would actually
make that a proposition
because we need to vote clearly to
remove
the previous recommendation that was
made
do you want me to re repeat what i've
said
or has everybody grasped what i've said
i've got to fill top of them there
phil yes just a quick one it may seem
that i'm making a bit of a meal of it
i think it's because i agree completely
what you were saying that we do need a
quick a rethink under present
circumstances but i think there is also
an ongoing issue of what happens to
recommendations from this committee
and i think i'm just just a reminder
that we need to make sure
these things are followed up or
abandoned as you as you say
well that's why i'm proposing that we
have we do abandon it
but we move it forward to the forward
plan
to deal with it in the light of a whole
lot of new circumstances
both internally from the the leisure
services contracts
but also externally from the pressures
that may come on
funding issues for all councils in in
the coming months
and short-term foreseeable future
so um i want to move it forward
but i want to move it forward properly
not losing the fact that we did actually
approve that minute
um it was approved so i would like i'm
making a proposition
that we remove that minute of the
need to review capital investment and
put it into the forward plan to
to revise that again in the new light of
circumstances
and i propose that as a way forward here
so we just don't
drop recommendations we make we actually
deal with them
and we're appropriately we close them
down and open them again
can i have a casual letter please i'll
check in that chair
yeah you can't you've voted to accept
those minutes chair so
they've been voted on and accepted those
minutes leave it as it is now because
this leisure contract is going to be
reviewed
and as i said a minute ago all issues
about funding
and under funding will come forward
during that debate
right um just to be clear then stacey
i would like to tidy up the point of
view from
making sure that we don't just drop
previous recommendations
but can we vote not to go forward where
a recommendation we've now accepted and
approved the minutes
i'm asking stacey for a a correct way
forward here
because i do value when we make
recommendations that they are worked
upon
but i think in the functional working of
this uh
committee we need to move forward stacy
can you just comment on the
procedural matter yes i think um matters
have moved on a little bit
since that first recommendation was was
made
um and and for members today and just to
confirm there's
a major contract management board that's
been set up internally
within the council yeah and that's
consisting of
um councillor cottle hunt kim councillor
hodgson
councillor hutchins councillor james and
councillor jones
and that is designed to be reviewing
matters such as this such as the leisure
contract
and then obviously it will need to be
reported to full council so can i
just make a suggest or their
recommendations will need to be reported
to full council together with with the
uh officer update because circumstances
have changed due to the
current pandemic so can i suggest that
you wait for the
findings and the recommendations from
those committees
and then bring it back to scrutiny at
that stage
because the difficulty that you've got
is you're
you're dealing with something that has
quite substantially changed
yes so i i think it's right to have it
on your forward plan
but i think you want to wait to see the
recommendations that come from other
committees
and after members are fully update as to
the current situation on the ground now
okay then going back specifically stacy
to the issue about
we disregarding a minute we've already
passed
and needing to lift that minute um
do we need a vote or or can we just um
make a new recommendation in the light
of what
your comment there that we wait until
these
other committees have sat and considered
the issue i think you can make a new
recommendation
today noting that the ground has shifted
slightly since the previous
recommendation
okay uh phil topham are you happy with
that that we move forward i hear what
you're saying about uh disregarding our
recommendations
and i don't want to lose your point but
i think we need to move forward
no i'm very happy and happy to move
forward you move forward
and even other points on that from a
committee um that we do pick up the send
in the action
uh the forward plan uh when we come to
it later in the agenda
yeah chair yes council leather
well just to say we're not ignoring that
recommendation at all because if you
read it it does talk about
significant capital investment in
partnership with
outside agencies it doesn't specify
which outside agency
we do make investments with very various
outside agencies north devon
plus is one of them so we're not
ignoring that recommendation at all
chair
okay then then here in the comments i'm
asking you as a committee that we can
move forward without any proposal or
second or
doing any voting here at the moment any
objections to that is committee
i see no hands in front of me shout out
forever hold thy peace
where did i hear that before but there
we go right
we are now leaving that uh minute number
let's go back to the minute number again
minute 69
both points will be picked up later in
the
um uh four plan that we will discuss
further in the meeting
thank you very much we go to
go back to the agenda
all right we go to declarations of
interest
you know the form um shout if there is
any declaration of interest
um agenda item number six agreements of
agenda items between part one and two
i have nothing under part one and two
action number seven
uh urgent matters brought forward with
permission of the chair
i have nothing urgent because we've been
under emergency times for the last six
months we're gonna say
so uh is there anybody who wishes to say
anything
very briefly under um with my permission
to bring forward
as urgent items i look to the committee
to see any hands up
i see no hands up quickly no
okay we close on agenda item number
seven
we move to the annual report pages 11 to
21
and to approve the annual report so you
have the annual report before you
i have to thank mary for her excellent
work
and preparing this on your report any
comments
any additions any alterations the
committee wished to make
i see no hands going up here oh yes i
got a hand from councillor leather
yeah the part partner evaluations now i
might be a bit
thick and some would probably agree yeah
you are
but could somebody explain those lists
this 6.8 and then the range of scores
one to seven is a maximum
six i mean can somebody just explain in
simple english what that
is these part revaluation forms are
given out
to people who've presented to this
committee then they come back with their
views now what does all this
4.95 can somebody just explain
that to me please i like things kept
simple i don't like
confusing things and i'm confused by
that
i would like to ask um our independent
member phil topham because i think phil
did an extremely
a lot of work on trying to get this
evaluation up and running
which is i think a very valuable thing
to get feedback after people have been
to the meetings
so phil topham can you make comment
please i wonder
yes uh sorry counselor leather if it's
been confusing
um the average when
people fill out the questionnaire they
have these
half a dozen questions to answer and
they are asked to
give their answer on a scale of one to
seven
with one being the lowest level of
agreement with the question
and seven being the highest level of
agreement
there isn't a naught because naughty's
used for
does not apply or don't know or haven't
got an opinion
so the average score is the number of
all the scores by the 18
participants um the total of those
divided by 18. so 6.8
it's nearly the top of the range so
that's that that's a high score
and 4.2 at the bottom that's the sort of
middling
score and the range on the right hand
column one to seven
is the range of scores from the whole
group of
partners who return forms does that make
it clearer
there's another
the range of scores i'm not quite clear
on why are some only three to six
like to what extent does the overview
and scrutiny committee provide you with
sufficient information
about its aims and and membership
that's a bit of a low score there isn't
it yes and
and and that's why i put it in there but
that means of the 12 people who returned
forms over the 18-month period the
scores
on that question ranged from three to
six
and why did we make it out of seven and
not out of ten
ah well arrange you know why is it not
one to ten
which would be easier i think to monitor
okay yeah i there there is a huge
science of questionnaire construction
and measurement
and the construction of scales
and i'm sure you wouldn't wish us to go
into that now no i don't this is what
i'm about
i'm a simple man phil i like everything
simple
and this looks a bit confusing to a
simple man like me
but thanks for your explanation thank
you well is there anything i could do to
make it
make it easier to understand
well from for me make it score out of 10
on all those
right okay
happy to answer any other questions jeff
well thank you very much phil just i'm
checking through that form i have one
question actually interesting that the
evaluations
um went from july 18 to march
20 with the 12 forms um interestingly we
had a difference of a council
and i mean it's a bit of self-pride here
i suppose
i would be interested know what the
difference in range was between the
older administration prior to may 19 and
the new administration
um because uh that would make but that's
just for my own
personal um monitoring because i do
think feedback is really important
um to be able to pitch things i and i do
pick up
kind of another's point about um you're
providing sufficient information with um
aims and
and and membership and maybe um we
should do more to highlight what
the aims and overview and objectives of
the committee are
so uh that's quite interesting and um
i'm quite
shocked that somebody returned to one um
to the very last bottom right hand
corner to what extent the committee
communicate with you about their
recommendations
and actions following your presentations
so um be interested to know what that
actually applied to
but i suppose confidentiality means that
we can't actually ask that detailed
question
or can we um
if you can give me a specific query by
email
i will do my best to answer it um
but what i think i'd like to do is to
its numbers
are a bit seductive really and bear in
mind that these are only 12 respondents
so it's a very small sample what i would
draw your attention to is the comments
involved below
the three comments involved because they
as i have said there
reflect and underline what people said
in the in the
original interview survey and i would
suggest that if the committee wants to
reflect
on its partner's view it is probably
more useful to look at those three
comments involved
rather than the numbers right
thank you very much then for that
comment any further comments
um first of all on the evaluation form
no hands going up then
any other comments about the annual
report
19 2019 2020.
we have a hand from councillor leather
thanks chad yeah just to say um
just to say that thank you for the
report i'll move that we accept this
report and i do know that the full
review
of the park partner evaluation forms is
scheduled
for this committee to discuss later this
year so sometime in the auto aspect but
i'm happy to propose that we accept
this report chair
uh we've got councillor newton
council newton
yes i i second that right
can we put it to the vote please and by
the way
this normally would go to the annually
meeting of the full council
which has not been done yet and i hope
it will go to full council at some point
okay so we've had a proposal and
secretary to adopt
the annual report plus the evaluation
form
uh proposed by councillor leather second
the black council and you
can we go to the vote please mary sorry
very quickly chair before we move to the
vote if
you don't mind um last time this was
uh done we took it to full council and
full council sort of questioned why it
was there
perhaps we could put it to a future
future council
but you could publish before that if you
wanted so
if you um were happy with this it's your
report
um we could publish it on the website in
advance of full council considering it
if they need to are you happy counselor
uh leather and counselor newton to uh
um put that into your recommendation yes
that's fine with me chair
yeah it's very happy crap okay so we've
got the uh
adopted uh proposed and seconded um
motion can we then take that to the vote
please mary
yes chair counselor coddle honking for
council afford
cancer report four
hearting
mckenzie four
council newton for
council pennington or
mr topham oh
jesus thank you very much indeed
we then move now to agenda item
number nine and consideration
of the forward plan pages 22 and 23 and
i must pay
a special thank you to uh council
ricardo hunken
and phil topham for putting together
this forward plan supplement have you
all got a copy of the forward plan
supplement put before you
sure if you haven't please
good looks like you've all got a copy of
the forward plan supplement
now what i we're supposed to do is chair
of this meeting
um we are in the old floor plan
was built on the four strategic
priorities of torridge
um i'd like us just to go around this
committee um
and talk very briefly each one of us
about what we see
is the priorities within the remittance
committee
in the coming 12 months because uh we're
in such varying times it's going to be
very very difficult
um to have a hardened fast forward plan
we need to be somewhat light on our feet
i note that our next meeting if it is
seven weeks away
comes on the ninth i think it's the
ninth of september
um so so that um you know we're
looking forward to that date possibly
for agenda but i do recognize how
our our offices are working at the
present moment and that may be a movable
feast as well
um but uh certainly from the floor plan
you have that supplement
and i like as a committee each of us
just to talk about how we view things
do you want me to go first or last or do
you want to do alphabetically committee
then i'll go first if you like okay and
um
there's there's a couple of really big
issues for me that i think in the short
term
and the reason i'm here today is
broadband i'm in riverbank house because
we have a broadband issue
in rural areas we have a very poor
download speed i've tried to sort things
out we've had new hubs from bt
we've tried to go to airbnb and uh we're
struggling a bit at the present moment
um we get timed out from doing all sorts
of different things so i'm here in
riverbank house
i realize now in the light of where we
are
uh broadband is vitally important
the second thing that i think is going
to be hugely important is the
generational divide that's going to come
down
from this pandemic um it's going to be a
generational divide
um it seems to me because those um
of the elderly population and torch has
a fairly aging population
a lot are still shielding and although
the uh
rules and regulations from westminster
have changed somewhat
um um a lot still of the elderly
population
given their conditions aren't going to
go very far and there's going to be a
huge lot of issues around there
balanced against the fact that our
youngsters and younger generation need
to go forward
we've already mentioned petroc in the 18
to 24 age group
and some of the youngsters are really
struggling financially at the present
moment i gather there is
seven thousand seven hundred um workers
in torridge
under the furlough scheme um and and
they'll be interested to see what
happens when that comes to an end
so we have that intergenerational divide
and thirdly which is background i
suppose i said to but thirdly is the
green agenda
because that still remains very much
with us
and we've learned an awful lot in the
pandemic
about doing things differently that's me
anybody else would like to follow to say
where they're thinking about what we
need to be looking and
and the wider broader spread of the
forward plan
nobody's putting their hands up
can you hear me anybody i got a hand i
think i'm here on my own sometimes
christian newton yeah chad that's
it's
a general comment and again i i
i'm new to this game having only been on
this committee for for a year
um and with the the
the unique situation that we find
ourselves in uh and the
the unknown um in front of us uh it's
probably even more so
uh i would i would say that we must
guard against
trying to do too much and that
we should actually concentrate on doing
a few things well
rather than trying to touch a multitude
of things
but actually not really being able to do
much about it because we're only
just touching the surface i like your
flow chart that you sent round
and i think actually we should apply
that to the
the especially the first four lines in
your flowchart
we should apply with rigor when we are
thinking about a subject
basically if we can't influence
something
then we shouldn't be talking about it
because
there's a great tendency for us to turn
into a glorified talking shop
where we actually discuss all sorts of
ethereal things
that we we might feel very passionate
about
but the reality is that actually we
don't
have either control or influence
over or significant influence and
we're basically wasting our time we're
also wasting
other people's time and officers time
bringing them in
to discuss those things we might feel
good about it when we actually walk away
but the reality is if we're not actually
able to do anything about it then we are
wasting time
uh we're also perhaps cooking
expectations which can't be delivered
because we might end up making
resolutions and
and recommendations but if they actually
are not going to puncture the bubble
somewhere and really actually
make something happen then you know why
are we doing it
so i'd just slightly caution i said i'm
a new boy but with a year's worth of
experience
i would caution about being
taking on subjects which are too broad
brush too
general and we should actually try to
look at things which have distinct focus
and we have a uh an organization that we
can really speak to
and perhaps influence if it's too
general and we can't actually pin
somebody against a wall to answer for it
then probably uh we're not going to gain
anything we might go away
having feeling good but that's not the
purpose of the committee the purpose of
the committee
is to provide is to ultimately downtrack
create or provide action um for the
better
of the community um so that's my view
that i just think we are
we're a bit loose at times with some of
the subjects we take on or how we
discuss them
uh enough of broadcasting me i'll shut
up
thank you very much um we have council
leather
sorry council langford first actually i
was going to say council langford was
before
me yes i apologize crazy langford you
were
above coastal leather that's fine thank
you very much
um just trying to be brief um uh and
similar to councillor newton having only
been doing this for a year
it's still feeling exactly what we can
and can't do but
um i do think um as you've implied we
might have to be prepared to be flexible
because we don't know what's coming
in the future to a certain extent and
everything we talk about um
and i'm going to mention just a few
things in a minute that i feel strongly
about but i do appreciate all of these
things i'll link to the economy
because if it if um the financial sys
situation isn't good enough we're not
going to be able to do anything
and i also feel very strongly when we do
invite people in or if we do want to
engage with
people about things i don't want to
engage with them and give them extra
work if they're doing a great job out
there
i don't particularly need to have them
to to give them extra work by doing a
presentation to us
um if if if it doesn't achieve anything
if
there's nothing there to change or help
in any way
um so um just some things that i i
i feel strongly about i still want to
address
um if officers can do it uh with their
workload and everything
um the play strategy i feel very
strongly
that um you know we need for the mental
health of young people
to be able to provide them with really
good places where they can play as we
come out of this lockdown
um again just coming back to leisure i
think that is really important it did
concern me a really concerned me as i'm
sure it did everybody else the report
that
steve sent out was it last week about
the possible
um pressure on the leisure services
um with many publicly owned leisure
facilities possibly closing down in the
future
uh because they can't afford to keep
going and a huge knock on to mental
health particularly of less affluent
members of our public um just very
quickly the the voluntary sector what a
great job they've been doing and we need
to continue to support them
at the same the nhs and one other thing
that probably links more to
the other overview and scrutiny
committee but comes back to with
westwood housing etc is housing
i think as a council we need to look at
affordable housing etc etc
but in the same way the housing agencies
um how with lockdown how important
it's been that people have a safe and
comfortable
family home uh to be in and we've got to
make sure that uh
that that's provided and people like
westwood housing
um are really doing the best they can
for us to
to give people good safe homes to live
in
thank you thank you council langford
then
we go to councillor leather thanks chair
well
looking at the um draft forward plan
supplement was put around in the various
bold headings at the top
some of them are kind of wish lists in a
way
maintaining the economy responding to
poverty these
are all important issues but i think as
councillor newton said
a minute ago and i agree with both what
council newton and council langford have
been speaking about
we really need to focus on what matters
and what we can have
a real change what we can affect a real
change in
part of our scrutiny job of course is
proposing policy
so we we can recommend to cancel any new
policies we want the council to adopt
but afford one thing on the housing
affordable housing
you may members probably realize and any
members of the public listening
we're having an awful job maintaining
this 30 percent on many of the sites
this
viability issue keeps cropping up now
time and again
and we're being whittled away with it
now this torres district council and i
know it's been raised
before during this new council can build
their own council housing but
if they've seen the verse to wanting to
do that or well we might have to set up
an arms length company
we might have to do this the point is
lots of small town and parish councils
are doing affordable housing schemes
of their own i mean cleveland are doing
the scheme
holes where they've had a scheme down
there so
i'd like us to look at the possibility
as a work item of torridge doing its own
affordable housing scheme
we've got land we haven't got to go and
buy land we do own some land that's one
thing
westwood housing they're running they
were gifted
they were gifted the housing stock from
torridge many years ago when it went
to tarka but i would like westwood
housing
to come and speak to us about their
policy on play provision
on their sites what policy have they got
is it to let it all run down and then
not replace it
so i'd like westwood to come
specifically to tell us about their
play provision policy um
the play strategy is important now we've
been hearing for months and months and
months
and the office chris chris can i just
i'm just trying to get
individual coaches to talk about their
own priorities just the present moment
okay
and that's what the original idea just
of this very brief part of the
discussion
and then can we then bring you know the
priorities in
as we discuss what we put on this
forward plan
that's why i'm mentioning what i see as
well there it is
i'm only giving you two up to now a
possible affordable housing scheme
yeah westwood housing to come to us to
discuss their policy on play provision
and the replacement of redundant
equipment a play strategy
and provision of that that that's
something torridge
i know we've lost to the officer who was
doing it but it keeps being kicked down
the road that one doesn't it's not good
enough
that that's happening and of course
a housekeeping thing is the review of
the partner evaluation form
uh which will come later in the year but
the community safety partnership again
will come later in the year so they'll
be on our
forward plan in any event but i'll leave
it but
as for the biosphere meeting climate
change emergency
with public participation forget that
for this committee
we've got a climate change committee on
turridge who are dealing with that
now when they come up with any
recommendations
we might want to look at that then but
it's not for us to start setting
out their work program i would argue
chair
leaving that for now thank you council
leather we go to chrysler hackett
thank you for calling me chair um can i
just
take up on a general point first of all
i agree somewhat with council newton
that we can't
battle on all fronts but what we have to
do
is make sure that where we are silent
it does not get misinterpreted that we
are content
with where we are i believe we do need
to make clear
where we have issues because if we
don't register our discontent on things
we will simply fall behind
i've spoken out in the past about health
inequalities about
ambulance response times about the fact
that in northern devon we have an
alarming
spike in suicides and the lack
of rural policing and our pcsos
now by making those points we have had
some successes
and i think if we don't make those
points we get overlooked
you mentioned yourself about super fast
broadband
and we did get a degree of satisfaction
in rural areas with the um
the broadband initiative was put
forward with connecting devon and
somerset there are black spots and i
know you live in one
but one issue that keeps coming up
is the lack of mobile phone uh
connectivity we have in a lot of rural
areas
particularly it's uh scientists did
cross
and in my ward of broadway widget
and um that needs
to be addressed because where you have a
lack of mobile phone
connectivity and superfast broadband you
do
not have investment in businesses
because simply it doesn't join up to the
network
thank you thank you councillor watson
oh thank you chair thanks for letting me
speak um
as i'm not part of your your your
committee i
it was just a little update that i'd
like to
say to chris i mean just well 10 minutes
ago i had a
a conversation with my contact at
westwood housing
and that contact is going to
try now to organize the
the meeting that we should have had a
few months ago
and and let me know about that and also
the site that we were going to visit
with 45
um affordable properties on it
are all taken so westwood uh westwood
alginate are doing some good somewhere
uh and they're looking for they're
looking for more more sites
to build more at this moment so
um i i can i can update you further
chris when she's come back to me
uh and i'll i'll talk to um
to talk to you okay
thank you very much for that update then
uh peter um
uh coach the watson for for for uh
thank you very much for that update as
well so also the broadband situation
that
airband now are going to start and roll
out fiber to properties
okay okay thank you that's right
yeah i'm just thinking i better declare
a personal not a prejudicial interest
there actually so i'll do that mary at
the end of the meeting or whatever i'm
required to do
um because it is such a personal
interest of mine from that point of view
anybody else i've got a hand up here
from council mackenzie
yeah um how's it i think that that
should be um
well a high priority um can i ask if
porridge has any
um housing officers inspectors that go
and inspect properties um you know
to see that they're up to scratch
because torridge obviously pays a hell
of a lot of money out in uh
housing benefits and things um and
in bediford there's a a lot of town
center you know
flats and things over shops there's lots
of like little bedsits and things
and i've seen a lot of those through my
work in outreach and
various other uh roles that i do
and some of them you wouldn't house a
dog in them
and we should be uh actively inspecting
these properties to say that they're
safe the habitable um you know
but we don't do that but we just you
know
have a form payout housing benefit you
know if the place is not the scratch we
need to be holding people accountable
and
i think that's part of my priorities on
housing
um especially in the town center
okay uh thank you for your comment uh
coach mckenzie
um i just wonder if um janet would like
to respond jenna's got her hand up now
janet can you respond to coaster
mackenzie please
can i just um advise council mackenzie
that that is an environmental health
function we do
have um housing inspectors in our
housing
renewal team and i'm happy to speak to
councilman
mackenzie outside of this meeting to
explain our role our function
and how that um how that operates okay
right any other yeah sorry
it's too hard i'm just going through
stacy first of all
our solicitor i was just going to
comment in relation to the payment of
housing benefit
i mean obviously um that those claims
are done free torridge but
what we can't do is specify what
properties they move into
so if a person is eligible for housing
benefit and they want to move into
a property unfortunately regardless of
the condition there's not much we can do
about that
um we're still going to pay the benefit
and they can still live there
and but as jan will say if we have a
complaint in relation to a pacific
property um then her team can go and do
an inspection in relation
to that thank you for the comment
any other hands want to make comments
now about the
councillor ford
chair yes please yeah very brief um
on two or three issues um i think going
back to council newton
and langford the fact that
um you might have only been here for one
year and my father always said to me
some cats can lap milk from birth and
some
some never learn o2 i think you've got a
lot to offer
and i do agree totally again which is
unusual for me
with probably my political leaning i'm
always soon to be
agreeing with a conservative but if they
talk sense you agree with them
and quite frankly you ever probably
concentrate with difficult times ahead
on a relatively narrow uh
sphere of problems or concerns to be
honest you know um
we can't influence history we might be
able to influence today and tomorrow
but going on to the ozone thing i do
want to ask something here
and it i will be rather measured because
it's just a specific house in my passion
i do
take on board that we need a better
relationship and an easier access
to westwood hosing actually i think
we're all finding that a struggle
but and i will be very then because i am
you know i've got a level a law and i
keep saying that but i'm not stupid now
i look it
the point is i ever empty properly on my
patch
that i'm aware the person that
was renting that sadly has got medical
history but has been brought to my
attention and that probably now has been
empty
for six months i've broke this
with westworld it's one of their
properties
my concern is and i'm assuming but some
assumptions are deadly gain that
westward probably is still
getting benefit for that or payment
therefore perhaps the urgency and i do
understand it's being difficult
because of the occupant that was there
and and mental health conditions but it
still doesn't help me
on my path if i know i've got a
perfectly good
little bubble that's empty um i don't
know whether anybody could
pick up on that how long do you know
because
it's looking to me the person won't come
back but it can't be
ignored indefinitely because yeah this
is not good for anyone thank you
yeah well thank you very much for your
comment there councillor ford
certainly there's a flavor of housing
issues coming through
um both with the quality of housing
affordable housing
and one of um and addressing issues
historical stuff with the
what was torque and westwood housing so
so there's a huge uh
response coming through from u.s
committee members uh looking at housing
issues
now go now to councillor harding
yeah thank you chair um yeah everybody
seems to be talking about housing which
is a brilliant thing i'm in our
parish here at woozary with the parish
hall uh
community hall committee are building
their own
uh social housing uh four one bedroom um
starter
units um so and that's great
and and the great thing is that the the
money is um going back into the village
in the community again so i would
love to see biddeford uh or torridge um
doing
something like as as a council um in
other places i i can't see
why they they just can't see it it would
work financially um
it's better than letting somebody else
get
profits for it and the figures look very
good for the um
community hall and uh it's a no-brainer
um the other thing is you know yes with
all the
um mental health problems going with the
lack of facilities now it's a really
good time now to push forward for
biddeford
um to westward i would love to see that
and i don't know what we can do about
that
but uh yeah basically i'd just like to
agree with councillor newton that we
need to hone our our um
our efforts on things that we can do
something about rather than
what we can't do anything about thank
you christopher harding again
housing comes through as a strong theme
from you uh counselor connor honkin
thanks and i agree with what's been said
i just wanted to say that i'm really
concerned about
unemployment in torridge um i know
there's going to be a high number of
redundancies
and a lot of people won't be able to pay
their mortgages um
so they will link together unemployment
poverty and
supporting mental health and i do agree
with what council
langford said we don't want to take away
people who are doing a really good job
already and give them extra work to come
to our meetings
but at the same time we do need to focus
on those things and
make sure that we can help where
possible but i don't know
the best way to go about doing that for
the forward plan
obviously housing is a massive one which
links to all of those things
and something that hasn't been mentioned
is
um brexit everyone's forgotten about
brexit at the moment
but we do need to be aware of trade
deals um
which will be happening and make sure
that they
these don't fall through the loop and
particularly for torridge the impact
that might have on agriculture
because a lot of the trade deals do link
to agriculture
and that's for me thank you very much
indeed
council caller honking right no further
hands on that part of the discussion so
um we go forward to actually put some
structure to just that those
comments we've had as a general
discussion i look at the calendar now
and it's the 22nd of july today
um seven weeks cycle was the normal
cycle and i do appreciate
how hard our officers are working at the
present moment
as a rule of thumb it's seven weeks
between each cycle
and that brings the next meeting to fall
on the
9th of september wednesday the 9th of
september
um it's not written still and we've got
to hold that we don't know how long the
covert conditions will go forward
because i understand uh
westminster must discuss the these
emergency powers again
in september to be whether they're going
to be reviewed or not
and so we've got one meeting then for
for september the 9th
we then go forward another 7 weeks it
takes us to november the 4th
and then if you do another seven weeks
it takes you in between christmas and
new year
so it shows you how little time we have
and picking up the comments that we
should be
focused on what we do we need to pencil
together the plan
that we can put something in for our
floor plan
for september um
bearing in mind that i think when it
comes to november we are statutorily
obliged
to have a csp meeting community safety
partnership meeting um
and if that should be pented in for
november stacy is that
appropriate sean stacy can you comment
on that as our officers please
sorry a thumbs up yesterday that's fine
that's fine with you yeah
november um the appropriate wednesday's
november the 4th
um is is on the diary for the 14 weeks
from today
um um so yeah um and if you're happy
with i take it i'm not got any comments
here from stacy
but that may be appropriate go back to
counselor leather again hands up
thanks chad well i'm just looking at
above me here our
schedule of committee meetings it's the
22nd of july today
and on the schedule up on the wall our
next meeting should be
uh on the 2nd of september
i just counted then okay after that it's
the 13th of october
then it's the 25th of november so and
then we go into january 20th of january
that's the list i've got above my head
there i apologize that i've miscounted
the
the weekly cycle so can you shake those
dates out again
yeah the next meeting of this committee
should be on
the 2nd of september yep
then the 13th of october the second
second september is two o'clock
yeah um october is the 13th at six
o'clock
yeah november the 25th is at two o'clock
yep 20th of january then at six o'clock
yep then it's the 10th of march at 2
and 28 of april at 6. okay
let's just concentrate on the first
three here okay
just to confirm the october meetings the
14th of october
sorry 14th of october yeah that's the
wednesday
yes i i have incorrectly done it on a
seven week cycle i thought it was a
seven week cycle
that i i i calculated on um
and um this appears to be on a
a six week cycle so i'm confirming then
that we are looking
at meetings tom on the second of
september
the 14th of october and the 25th of
november
that's correct yeah that's correct and
those will stay with us
providing all things remain as the new
normal if you like
yes yeah could i make it a request i
mean
members can debate it as they wish but
whilst we're under these conditions
um meetings in the evening require us to
have the town hall open
and also require us to be having i mean
this extraordinary resource goes into
running a zoom meeting surprisingly
enough
it's much easier and more efficient for
us although i accept less publicly
accessible
if meetings could be held during the day
okay committee any comments on sean's
comments i've got a hand up here from
um mr topham
you're muted mr toblin
sorry uh no my comment is about
something else it's not about meetings
i'll come back to you again can you
raise your hand when it's appropriate
then thank you uh coach mckenzie
um well i start up i take about what uh
sean said there about the the timings
and the meetings and stuff um
quite a lot of us still work and it's
quite uh a chore to try and get the time
off or or to be able to you know attend
these meetings during the day
um i know that it was alternating
between ten and six to facilitate that
i mean if that could that continue you
know that's that's my point of view
because i find it hard to attend
meetings in the day a lot of the time
um yeah that's just from my point of
view from from my
own personal circumstance of work
okay so just to clarify the times then
tom
uh please second of september is at 2
p.m
15th of october is at 6 p.m yes chair
and 25th of november 2 p.m currently
school
2 p.m no then
the 2 pms are we are happy with okay
um very important discussion because
there is a balance here between
we need working members to be involved
in the council
and evening meetings allowing members of
the public who are working to
witness meetings if they so wish to um
i will propose that we have six o'clock
on the sick um on the 14th of october
if there is a secondary just quickly put
into the vote and see where we are on
this bearing in mind
sean's comments any second or for the 6
p.m on the second
on the 14th of october
there is counselor leather yeah i'll
check nature
so we've got a secondary from 6 p.m then
we hold the meeting at 6 p.m on the 14th
of october
okay proposed by myself second by
counselor leather can we
quickly just test that to the vote barry
for the committee to say yay or nay
yes sure cuddle it's a coddle honking
council ford oh here we go again
four
four councilman mckenzie
four councilman newton
councillor pennington four mr topham
unanimous chair right so we've got the
structure for the meeting
dates then can we
populise these dates with uh
gender items sorry i've got a
back road here hand up mr topham
yeah sorry to just take a step back i'm
i'm rather surprised that no one has
actually mentioned kovid 19
and its continuing impact on the
community
other than its indirect effects so
is this because people are not concerned
or
because there are there are issues about
for example
test and trace in the local area
and it's not at all clear what is
happening
in northern devon as it were i think
they although there is a
an outbreak management plan the details
of it
at the moment and given nash and i know
we're a very low infection area
but it is probably not a good time to be
complacent when the virus is still
very much in the wider population so i
just noticed
that no one else has brought it up
and the impacts that we may have to
prepare for which indeed i think taking
councilman newton's point will indeed be
very specific issues
where we want to talk to people like the
nhs
like petrol like the public health
people in devon
and so on and so forth about how we can
prevent mitigate any effects of the
virus in our area
okay for me that is a priority
okay thank you for that uh mr tobham
then uh we'll add that to one of the
suggested items that we've come to
discuss
in a moment um going back to
the the the structure of the meetings
we've
agreed now um is
it uh we've got to put the community
safety partnership in there somewhere
um and can i suggest that that is done
on the 25th of november at a 2 p.m
meeting
is that within our time limit um um
stacy uh janet to to to fulfill our
statutory
duties because that is a joint meeting
usually with north devon district
council
that's more than 12 months since the
last csp
yeah in terms of our statutory duties
that's fine
and obviously that the caveat of that is
um arrangements with north devon
and um i would imagine um superintendent
toby davis
would want to present like he did last
year so it's down to his availability as
well but we can
we can start asking the questions then
committee can i ask your agreement
pairing our minds the comments that we
don't scatter
too widely that we focus on pacific
issue
that we pencil in november the 25th 2
p.m
to be a request with north devon
district council on the community
safety partnership um anybody objecting
to that
no hands going up so can we pencil in
csp as the primary uh
agenda item for the 25th of november
yes we'll do that we've come to a vote
later on that one as well i don't see
any hands going up
that takes us back now to the 2pm
meeting on the
2nd of september we've all had a various
topics
um coming forward um i don't want to get
into wide discussions on each topic
but we have things coming through it
seems to me on
housing on covet
on unemployment
brexit
[Music]
broadband
and i think that's coming up and the
play strategy
here on on that one can i just make a
request i mean
picking up on councillor leathers
kicking it down the can comment
i i'd quite like to get uh a draft of
the play strategy to you on the
september meeting if possible
thank you for that comment sean um how
long do you think that'll take on the
agenda
is it uh well it's an interesting one
i'm not sure it'll take long to present
but it might take members a while to
debate ah
okay um so if i pencil in what um
45 minutes on that again that would be
fine i think
it's a really important issue it's been
it's been around for a while the
implications of what we're talking about
are
far reaching so um i think 45 minutes is
is what are they yeah and just for the
members of the public who may be
watching
um play strategy um
is is uh a thing that we
are looking at all the facilities across
torridge
um available for for the residents
in broad terms yes yeah in broad in
broad terms
chair what the strategy will try to do
is it
obviously will come to you in draft form
um but it will try and
uh consider things like what provision
we have available
what resources we we put into play
um it will think about what ambition we
have as an
authority for our role in play
because obviously it's a discretionary
activity so you do it at your discretion
and then it'll also make recommendations
uh about future activity and we can then
align resources to delivery
right okay thank you for that is there
any
other um issue that members would want
to bring forward to the second september
meeting
i'm going to hand up here from
councillor mckenzie
yes it's not to do with a forward plan
um i was just going to
ask ask if i could be excused for the
rest of the meeting because i've got a
kobit 19
test and track meeting at 12 o'clock for
uh with devon county council for the
supported living um
thank you very much for your
contributions this morning thank you
chad
take care now close to the leather
yeah i'm pleased to hear that from sean
about um bringing that
draft play strategy forward to the
september meeting
i i'm not finished yet chair i'm sorry
go to another apologies
uh you're jumping in a bit sharpish
there if i might with respect says here
because counselor mcguff you know has
put forward
proposals to do with a disability swing
in the park victoria park in biddeford
and things like that have been waiting
and obeying until we get this spread
play strategy document before us so it
is
it is pretty key that we get this dealt
with and further than that
um i don't know if we can get
west windows in it at the same one where
it'll have to be the next meeting
because it's play provision as well that
really concerns me with them
well there's a suggestion that um we
invite westwood housing would that be
appropriate sean
it could be i mean all i'm mindful of is
that
if you think of today's meeting already
we're where
we are nearly two hours in and and we've
only really got on to the substantive
item of the agenda
now right um if we're going to have a
heavy debate
about play you know you are looking at
three-hour meetings but you know you can
you can go you can meet for as long as
you like
and and uh but we would need to think
about
scheduling these things because if we're
going to invite people from westwood
they mightn't want to sit through uh
debate on other items it's it's quite a
commitment
at that length i hear a comment okay
um then therefore uh proposal that we
focused
on that play strategy for the the
2nd september um
anybody want to object strongly to that
two hands cursor hack it
thank you chair sorry um when you
mentioned a super fast broadband
i feel that that goes hand in hand with
mobile phone
um communication could that be added
to that item so you have connectivity
with mobile phones
and super fast broadband many of the
companies
do the same um like for example i get my
broadband through ee
okay what i'm trying to focus on now i
do i think there's a feeling towards the
play strategy at the present moment
unless you tell me wrong for the meeting
of the september the
second september
and up from council newton
i would agree that chair and just to
follow on from what was said before
i would recommend that you we keep
westward housing separate from the play
strategy not only could the potential
size of the item to be taken but
secondly our interest in westwood
housing
goes significantly further than just
their play
their play area provision um because i
think we want to
uh look at all
a number of aspects concerning westward
um
that have been mentioned earlier so i
think otherwise it would get
completely hijacked by the play play
strategy
okay then we we
focus then on the play strategy for the
second of september as the main
single topic for that meeting can i make
that a proposition that we do that so we
can move forward
um any seconder
i'll send it chair okay second country
leather
go to the vote please we have a proposal
and secondary
chair i thought we're voting on any on
recommendations yeah sorry i'm on block
yes okay
um then we go to the 40th of october
at 6 pm meeting bear in mind young
people may be involved
any suggestions any hot priority that we
want to make that the central topic to
westwood housing then chair
westwood housing any other proposals
i see no hands
will you propose western housing than
council leather
yeah i will propose westward housing and
i take council newton's point it is a
wide
ranging discussion besides the player
provision i do accept that
any seconder for
i'll second that uh check yeah we've got
question newton there
so therefore guys we have the main
agenda items
um for uh the
second of september at 2 p.m at play
strategy
which sean will be leading us on
um on the 14th of october we go to
westwood housing
at a 6 p.m meeting and on the 25th of
november at 2 p.m
we do a community service
partnership meeting in joint with north
devon at 2 pm
i propose that that is our forward plan
we can add
if we want at the next meeting to the
14th and the 25th that's where you so
wish
so i make that proposal is there a
second or please
i'll say no chef right that's a
secondary have you got that to proposal
mary
for those states and times yes
westwood housing for the 14th and a
joint north devon csp on the 25th
yes yeah okay we list all the other
things we've had in our discussions but
we go to the vote for that and i propose
a second can you take the vote please
councillor cuddle honking four
council afford
are you anonymous thank you very much
indeed committee i think
uh i would like to add a special thanks
to sheryl coverhunken
and phil topham for preparing the
four-pound supplement that's been put
before us as well this morning
um i think that brings us to the end of
the agenda just let me make sure that we
have got the end of the agenda
yeah uh we've done before thank you all
very much for your comments and
attending this morning
and look forward to being with you on
the 2nd of september and
keep well keep safe and thank you to the
work of all our officers
within this council bye-bye everybody